i remember a few years ago he said he
got this job writing on the show and he
was like yeah you know there was no
effort it was so easy i just um
you know i didn't have to chase it down
and my mind was kind of hurting so
what do you mean what
brooks before you moved to hollywood
what was the picture you had in your
mind of what it meant to be a working
hollywood screenwriter that's a great
question um
if before i went to hollywood my thought
of being
a working screenwriter is
um
sort of non-stop five projects at a time
this one that one the other one and um
you know finishing one and and getting
on to another one i think that's
pretty much what i would
think back back then
so when you're at nyu or even before
you had this vision that it would be
non-stop work phone ringing
people wanting to have meetings maybe
yeah yeah so um yeah the idea made it
was
um
what's so interesting is that a lot of
people talk about oh have you made it if
you broke it in or whatever um and it's
it's kind of amorphous when you go what
does that mean to you that you made it
and people usually go screensiders i
don't really know so that was certainly
the case for me i mean when i started um
i was making movies with my friends in
high school and it was so much fun and i
just was like look nothing in my life is
more fun than this how can i
do this as much as possible and then i
was like oh well i can go to study at
nyu film school and i went and stuff and
then at that point i just
i would have probably if i was pushed to
define making it i would have thought
yeah making something that's widely
released and everybody knows you and
your whatever and my thought was yeah
you're sort of working constantly
that's probably how i how i thought
about it back then
in terms of the process of the work
did you think that it would just be as
easy as sitting down and you know
having a glass of wine or whiskey or
whatever and just music in the
background it's all pours out or did you
realize that it would be
more painstaking uh
that's interesting um
well because the way i started um with
my friends it was
there was a social aspect of it it was
like i wanted to do this with my friends
i liked them and we had this idea to do
together and it was fun so there was a
very team oriented start to when i made
movies and then on my own i would do my
own experiments and then as i got to
film school i learned
that expressing my own voice was really
powerful and satisfying in a way so i
became
pretty good at
working on other people's projects and
supporting them
co-writing
and collaborating in groups and you know
leading following and everything in
between
um so the um
so the process
was sort of intoxicating engaging
fascinating and like layered and levels
and so i um
so yeah so the the creativity the
creative part of it and the process oh
it always came pretty naturally and was
deeply engrossing to me so
there were things that back then i would
consider hard or difficult or whatever
um
about the process but
the way i approach it now
it's never hard it's always easy and
it's because
um i frame it in a way that makes it
easy whereas back then i didn't know how
to do that so i was generally having fun
but very often going wow this is so hard
this is difficult i was looking at the
the what was going on in certain ways
without realizing that was undermining
the power of my process
and when did you realize that it was
much different than
your first visions of what a working
successful hollywood screenwriter is
yeah that's that's a good question so i
right out of nyu film school when i was
22 years old i made a rote directed and
produced feature
and then we kind of ran out of money
and it took a couple years to kind of
get edited and put out there and i ended
up taking it on this really fun
college tour because it was a college it
was a movie about my friends on the nyu
soccer team and how we were pretty good
at playing soccer but really good at
drinking after games um and that's
probably a more interesting
encapsulation of what it actually was
but like uh there were some good aspects
of it but it was really kind of like a
graduate level student feature it was
kind of you know we were 22. um
but i but i took that film to um all
these different college campuses on this
college tour and i played it for uh for
for a month
in new york city at this off-broadway
space called new york city's guerrilla
cinema that we created and it was a lot
of fun so um
so i was getting
a first-hand experience of how
uh
challenging it can be to get people in
the seats you know i did this movie
people that saw it liked it for what it
was um and it was like well geez how do
i how does that work how do you get
people it's not just i made a movie and
everybody shows up and it's not exactly
like you know it didn't get into
sundance so i didn't have the you know
kevin smith experience or richard
linklater those guys um
uh so um
but it was the whole thing was fun the
the craziest promotion we did in at that
time
at one point even me or my friend that
was doing it because actually
in addition to screening my movie we
screened my friend's independent feature
too so like mine was odd nights his was
even nights we both did it together so
we were both promoting these two
independent films
together at one point we even put like a
gorilla suit on around the street we're
doing all sorts of things and um so
how uh so i got a firsthand experience
of what it's like to be the business
part of it how do you get people how
difficult is it to tell people about
your movie and get them to care about it
and who is going to care about this
movie because i wasn't thinking about
that i was just thinking about my own
voice and something that felt true to me
at the time you know for good and for
bad
how is that picture of being a working
hollywood screenwriter different now
well
i think the creative part of it is
the same i'm no more or less creative
than i ever was
um
and my love of it is basically the same
but i'm able to
look at the process in a way that's
uh deeper
and more fun
and easier
um and so
the quality of my
choices that are going to be
more impactful they come more often and
they come at a greater flow and when i
have the ideas that are just a little
bumpy or not quite as strong
i don't get hung up on them so it's sort
of the grace of my
efficiency has increased significantly
and the way i think about it and the way
i allow myself to have more joy more
often so my creative process is
profoundly different although like
if you ask me one single question i had
to have a creative answer to that now or
when i was 22 would be kind of the same
but my craft is profoundly different and
how that relates to um the way i see
working
writers
you know and myself it's it's um
my creativity will be that i'll be hired
by producers to work on some sort of
project and um
and then i show up and we're we see it
through fruition and it just
and there's sometimes overlapping
projects and there's sometimes lulls in
between and then when there's a lull in
between i'm writing my own new spec
material so i'm always writing um and
there's joys of writing my own spec
material and there's joys of writing on
assignment
you know i mean the money part of the
assignment guaranteed is nice
but it's really
the deeper
joy there for me is i'm working with a
team of people and we have to find out a
way where
i'm loving it and they're loving it um i
mean ultimately they get the final say
but they hire me because they really
want my my view right you know because
um
there's something i didn't either a
sample or the way i pitched an idea to
them that they felt like yeah this you
know this guy can really contribute so
um
so it's that creative flow that i told
you about that's fully there when i'm
doing spec work um and
it's
it's playing well with others in a
sandbox it's really kind of that simple
and there's a whole complication to it
but it really is that simple so um
uh
and and i guess the other thing is that
there's
a piece with the sort of freelance
nature of it the feast and famine the
busy and the flow and and the the
paradox is the more relaxed you are
about
when projects come when doors close and
how you respond to them um
the easier things happen
um and and the times in my career when i
was like hey zegs i got to make it
happen i was inadvertently pushing it
away
you know it's like the um the cool kid
in high school you know this person is
like you know he you know all the guys
liked him the girls liked him he was he
wasn't doing anything he was just kind
of cool you know and so um we all have
that cool person inside us um and maybe
some of you were that cool and the funny
is if you talk to one of those people um
they might not make they might not even
have seen themselves as the cool person
but like um
but there absolutely is that part of all
of us that has that sort of charisma our
own authentic charisma and when we show
up
with that part of ourselves in a meeting
uh in the um the outreach part of the
game um where we're there's no
desperation we're not boring we're just
um at ease we're ourselves what ends up
happening is we're um
it's about connecting dots so that we
make ourselves the exact dot that we
want to be and then the buyer of the
script is the exact they're looking for
that dot and that's how they connect so
um
yeah i don't know if that makes sense it
does and i want to talk more about law
of attraction and things later um yeah
and and you had some great videos on
your channel about that as it relates to
story
what if things aren't so joyous
and you know that in in terms of staying
with a project and playing well in the
sandbox there are going to be times
where you're challenged and maybe you
didn't think of that before when you
were at nyu because it was all fun and
everybody was sort of
you were in this together and you could
have drinks afterwards or whatever it
was you knew each other well
but now the stakes are different how do
you how do you view it now because
things don't always go well in sandbox
yeah so um well my experience at nyu was
was awesome and very competitive um at
least because i'm a couple of persons so
maybe i was bringing that to it um so it
was it was lots of fun and it was a
great experience but it was you know
there was actually about half the people
there were kind of still figuring stuff
out and then the other half were kind of
killers and they were they were getting
after it um
so um
to me that side of it those pressures
were were similar but to your point
that's different like you know nyu is
like we paid the money we get the thing
that's it in the marketplace it's like
we put up or we don't get employed you
know i mean so so there's those
pressures
that are really different but ultimately
it's it's the same game it's like um i
either have
an idea that's going to contribute to
this producer's vision of what they want
to do with the project
or don't and so um when i show up and
have a meeting and share my take on
something or um
or they've already hired me and i do a
draft it's like i just i don't can do
the best that i can do and then um they
look at it and and then we go from there
i mean it's um so it's
so yes the the doors close um
and oftentimes people will
frame that situation of a closed door as
a challenge or terrible or this or that
or the other and um i understand that
and i have empathy for that and it's
just um
it's paying attention to the wrong thing
and it's actually a self-imposed
limitation to kind of even think of it
that way you just say um
you just count the wins you know this is
a win this is a win this is a win and
then the winds stop at some point but
like
um and it sounds like pollyanna-ish
because it is and yet um
as i've tried that sort of mindset it's
just hey it feels better it's real fun
and it works better because again you're
shifting to that cool kid in high school
everything's just it says okay you work
it out it's either this okay yeah this
door closed doesn't matter there's one
behind it and then okay that one goes
fine then there's one behind it and the
more we focus on that
it really does the paradox is the more
we're not attached to when the door
finally opens the faster they open
the watch pot never boils kind of that's
right it absolutely never boils in
hollywood and you cannot be desperate
and you can't be boring um and so
the way to not be desperate and the way
to not be boring is the way to not be
boring is being authentic to yourself
and the way to not be desperate is
realize that it's okay it's gonna work
out
the universe is on the job you you do
your stuff i go up i i make the best
creative choices i can i'm either i'm
speccing material i'm working with this
partner or whatever and um and it's it's
gonna work out
did you always think like this
no
not at all that was the thing so um i
was always
i always loved it right and i've loved
it and i was very productive there's
some people that have like a motor and
they go and go and go and that's sort of
how my
sort of you know i made 50 short film
experiments before i even got to nyu and
then um at nyu a ton more right so i was
just i could just go um
and um
i would what most people do
see what's going on out there
and um and if things were going well i
would feel good if things were not going
well the door closed i would feel bad
right so um
and that is a terrible way to live in
general i mean the way most people do it
in a sense because
it hooks us into um
the roller coaster and this business is
very much
that sort of cyclical up down there's
there's these things happening beyond
what we can completely control
so um
so what i would do
is
you know hustle and get excited and kind
of effort my way this that and you know
i could make things happen and things
were good and i would progress
but the progression of my career
literally happened so much faster when
i'm i'm focused and i have a goal and i
know where i'm going but i'm not um i'm
i'm just not hooked into it it's going
to happen or it's not this is going to
be i'm just i'm i'm good with whatever
happens and it's um
and it's a practice you have to be able
to practice that in little ways and in
big ways and as i in my career was able
to practice that more often
a
my existential experience of life got
better i just felt better about me
and um and milestones got
crossed just much faster this milestone
that most it all it was easy no effort
everything's easy
um and it's a practice and so um
yeah so back in the day i didn't know
any different so i didn't i didn't know
to do it that way and i have a uh an
accountability partner uh who's a
professional tv writer and i remember a
few years ago he said he got this job
writing on the show and he was like yeah
you know there was no effort it was so
easy i just um
you know i didn't have to chase it down
and my mind was kind of hurting so
what do you mean what what's wrong with
this i spent my whole life hustling and
making things happen and he just i
realized that he was
in this place where
he was a valuing not hustling not
efforting letting things be easy
and i didn't realize that was possible
and if it was possible that it could
actually work and if it could work it
actually felt better and so in talking
to him and then reading a lot and
you know this is sort of law of
attraction stuff and you know
you know not getting caught up in some
of the woo-woo aspect of those things
but really looking
at the tangible more grounded aspects of
them and then trying them and as i tried
them everything got better i it felt
felt better i enjoyed it more my
creative process got
easier more powerful more consistent
my job became
i get up and i'm happy
and um
and then oh yeah what's going on out
there and uh is secondary you know what
i mean and it's again it's not 100 i'm
not like all rainbows and butterflies
but um
if you talk to people that i work with
um
they'll pretty much say that most of the
time
i'm feeling pretty happy and balanced
and and it's because i'm in the habit
i'm in the habit of whatever whatever um
whatever happens to me out there i
respond in a way
that just um
is aware of the of the sort of the
abundance and the bigness and the
greatness that's there around some of
the the challenges and
you know the pieces of the challenges
does that make sense it does and balance
is something that's very important to
you this is sort of the scales
it is it is i you know um
yeah i would say yes certainly certainly
flow is the word that comes up for me
that when i'm in a state of flow
um that's when it's easy it's effortless
it's just fun and it's like you get that
time warp experience
work
you played a lot of sports
did you have to retrain yourself because
you said before that you were
competitive
is that helpful uh i love that you
brought up sports because um
i've been
so i played uh soccer in college i was
captain of the nyu team and intensely
competitive
um
and
nyu is a division three school so
division one schools are like they're
all about it and division three schools
are students that also play right so but
i wanted to study the film school so i
was there but i was really competitive
too so um
this idea of how much
winning
matters and how to um
sort of make sense of winning in the
scope of things and and how to
it it absolutely fascinates me and it
completely relates to this whole idea of
mindset because again the same paradox
that we talked about with hollywood is
like if you're too desperate for
something you're actually pushing it
away
and in sports if you're too desperate
for hitting a free throw shot or
something happening in soccer or
whatever it is you can't you got to be
loose and you got to have that flow it's
this it's exactly the same thing and
that's actually one of the ways i was
able to sort of
find value in the law of attraction
ideas um
you know and sort of just you know not
not pay too much attention to the
metaphysical parts of it because they
might be true but if it's metaphysical i
can't really sort of measure it or make
sense of it but i knew damn sure that
when i played sports if my mindset was
confident and easy and active and
flowing
that the numbers my stats were much
better than if i was freaked out or if i
was worried about outcome what if we
lose what if i miss what if hollywood
doesn't come walking right so it's all
the what ifs what ifs and so
um it absolutely was a direct connection
for me to sort of take what i learned as
an athlete and then what i
because i've also coached a lot of kids
in in sports as well my own kids and i
even coached a high school soccer team
for
a season which was amazing and um
i love that mindset stuff it just makes
it makes a big difference um
certainly in sports absolutely in
entertainment and really it crosses over
pretty much anywhere
you